avec le retour des beaux jours et les
vacances de Pâques le public se pressent
dans les parcs de loisirs Eurodisney qui
tentent de sortir de ses difficultés
économiques faites l'arrivée du
printemps avec de nouvelles attractions
notamment le pays des contes de fées
c'est un hommage à la littérature
enfantine les contes pour enfants sont
recréés par des paysages miniatures à
bord de petites embarcations le public
voyage dans l'univers de la petite
sirène d'Andersen ou de pierre et le
loup de Prokofiev il y a aussi
l'évocation des côtes orientaux avec
Aladdin et la lampe magique du génie
autre attraction le petit train du
cirque qui permet aux visiteur de se
balader à travers les paysages du pays
des contes de fées et le parc de
Marne-la-Vallée présente également de
nouvelles parades que l'on voit à
l'image l'une d'entre elles la parade de
printemps évoque le carnaval avec de
grands chars colorés et des danseurs